Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now, you can discover Canada and there are many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is, can I have it and go find my own place? And like more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes.
And I did. I got an Airbnb. a little apartment. It faced a park. It was so lovely. I loved the host. And I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah. And I was near a grocery store. I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know. It just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff, National Park. Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean,
we love it. Love it. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at amex.ca slash yamex. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi, everyone. We have a fun, fun episode today. It's an All About Character episode. Here's a hint. In real life, this person is my neighbor. And in fact, we carpooled here today. That's right. It is all about Creed Bratton today on Office Lady 6.0. And Creed will be joining us in the studio a little later for our fan Q&A. And I can tell you all, it's a delight. He's just wonderful. Mm-hmm. Start to finish. Yes, the real deal. Well, you know we like to kick things off with the show Bible, and I have been very excited to read the show Bible for Creed. I know. It is wonderful. But we got a fan letter from a fan who wrote her own.
This was so impressive. It came in from Cindy R. in Sydney, Australia, who said, okay, ladies, this isn't a question, but a list of facts, quotes, and moments that my family and I started collecting about six years ago in an effort to better understand creed. They have been doing this for six years. Six years, her family. They have reached the conclusion that he might not be understandable. Cindy went on to say, looking at this list now, I think we may have written the Creed section of the show Bible.
And lady, she did. I compared their list to the show Bible, and their list is actually more detailed. No way. Yes. So I am going to read her family's list. Now, they also included things from deleted scenes, which I'm not going to read because the rules of the show Bible say that only aired material goes in the show Bible. But still, check out her family's list. Here we go.
Creed. Wanted criminal. Definitely stole blood. runs a fake ID business, has been in multiple cults and is also potentially bisexual. Hyde's true identity. Stole the name Creed Bratton
from someone named Creed Bratton. Commits tax fraud implied to have killed someone on Halloween. Doesn't appear to know what his job is, where he works, or any of his coworkers. When swapped, he doesn't seem to notice or care that he's eating a raw potato
instead of an apple. We talked to Crete about that. Attempted to fake his death at one point, has a daughter, his parents are still alive, he grows and eats mung beans in his desk, doesn't appear to know any modern technology. Internet texts nothing. Which might explain something else we talked about with Cree.
Creece. Creed wants three chairs. What are they for? We don't know. He uses the woman's bathroom, has never owned a fridge. Love stealing. Literally says, I love stealing, I love taking things, has definitely done drugs, sells Kelly a tapeworm, and also has a worm guy for worms. Mm-hmm. Has a whole worm guy. No. The character of Creed lives near the quarry,
ate an ice pack, called it a blueberry slurpy pouch, but somehow didn't die. Is very knowledgeable about marijuana strains? Used printer ink to dye his hair. He can't do cartwheels, has four toes, uses a disco ball as a rearview mirror, is very good at Dance Dance Revolution, hates Betty White. Do you remember that one? I had to look this up. No, I don't remember that. I guess in nepotism, he starts following Michael's nephew on Twitter because he isn't talking about Betty White. Doesn't want to hear any more about Betty White. No more. Leave it alone already. In search committee, Creed says, quote, I love my kids. I love ceramic. I love my job. I love wrestling.
He's already made his tombstone. He thinks he's learning scuba at Dunder Mifflin, and he's definitely been flashing people. But, you know, quote, that was just hanging brain. That's so gross. He can catch fish with his bare hands. He prints his own money, and he does not know what a Toblerone is. That's really funny. Quote, how did I get this long triangle? Yes. I loved that. So that is a pretty impressive list, right? It really is.
It really is. Now, there are a few things that were in the show Bible that did not make their family's list. They are that the character of Creed was in an iron lung as a teenager, that he is a chessmaster, has a Swiss passport, has friends in China, and has an alias. William Charles Schneider. Yeah. And he transfers all his debt to William Charles Schneider. There you have it. That was so impressive.
His show Bible, the facts of creed, are so entertaining. There's a lot of crime. There's a lot of shenanigans on Tom Foolery. I don't know why I'm saying all these ye oldy terms. Well, I thought it might be fun to go through our digital clutter, lady. You and I actually have some shared digital clutter that I have. have held on to. It is our text thread with Creed. We have been texting together the three of us for years. Yeah, we have our office peeps text thread, but we've got a side thread that's just you,
me, and Creed. Yep. And I want to share with you guys what it consists of. First of all, he always calls himself Grandpa Creed, and he refers to me as Pumpkin, because remember, he has that line on the show, Pumpkin's out. Yep. And so he calls me Pumpkin. And he always calls Jenna Jen. That's his nickname for her. You'll hear him say that in our interview today. He is the only person in my life who calls me, Jen, and I love it. Okay. Are you ready for an overview of our Creed texts? Yes. I thought this was really fun when you said, lady, I think we need to dig in to our text thread with Creed. I was looking at it. We found very funny things. He sends us a lot of wacky stuff, memes and the gifts and all that stuff.
But he also sends us pictures from his trips with his grandkids. inspirational quotes, like this one that he said is one of his favorites. And we've shared it before on the podcast, but since today is all about Creed, and this is one of his favorite quotes, I want to share it again. I love it. Creed wrote to us and said, I thought I'd send you my favorite cat quote from Alan Watts. When a cat falls out of a tree, it lets go of itself. The cat becomes completely relaxed and lands lightly on the ground. But if a cat were about to fall out of a tree and suddenly make up its mind, that it didn't want to fall, it would become tense and rigid and would be just a bag of broken bones upon landing. In the same way, it is the philosophy of the Tao that we are all falling off a tree
at every moment of our lives. As a matter of fact, the moment we were born, we were kicked off a precipice, and we are falling, and there is nothing that can stop it. So instead of living in a state of chronic tension and clinging to all sorts of things that are actually falling with us, because the whole world is impermanent, be like a cat. You know, I think Creed lives that. I do too. You know? I love that.
I do too. Well, you know, he also will always text us happy birthday, holiday greetings. One year, he texted us, happy New Year to you and your cats. And then he sent a video of a cat figuring out how to open a door. It was genius. My cat, Andi used to do that. We had a conversation about it. But we'll also hear from him for just no reason at all.
Like the time that he randomly sent us a video where a dog and an elephant become friends. And then he texted, oh, come on, ladies, I'm a blubbering mess after this one. He really loves videos where animals like do cutie pie thing. Right. Or when animals help each other out. Yes. Animals working together. This is a thing.
This is a theme. So, yes, the theme is usually animals being really cute. But then every once in a while, we get a curveball. Like, there was a 15-minute dance video he sent us. I remember this. I loved it. You loved it. It was from a French theatrical company titled, oh, Jenna, I'm probably going to get this wrong.
Do you want me to read it? Yes, will you? Okay, here, give it to me. Oh, yes. Well, I'm going to butcher it as well. Here we go. Ria de Grave. of Marguerite Borda
and Pierre Menier. Exactly. But probably I said that wrong. So that's the title. But then when you click on it, there's a description of this dance. Yes. A 15-minute dance.
And the description says, where in a space invaded by mud, eight couples strive to dance the minuet in the rules of the art. And then Creed wrote under it, enjoy this, ladies. Give it some time. It's an investment.
I remember receiving it, and I remember clicking on it and thinking, I must watch this. I remember watching it thinking, I would have never probably found this, if not for Creed. Correct. This is a fascinating piece of art. Yes. Well, we also check in with him, especially when he's on the road touring. One time we reached out and asked him how he was doing, and he wrote this. He said, I'm in Philadelphia for a two-week tour.
It is so cold and snowy, but I love it. miss you girls i mean it's so simple but it's just so sweet i know i also loved our text thread when we were writing our book and we reached out to him for our audiobook and he wrote us the most awesome jingle we thanked him profusely in our text and then he texted us back you're my girls i have no choice grandpa creed takes care of his brood isn't that so sweet yeah i think we should hear it Here's a tall tale you could call it a yarn About the office ladies and the show they spawned They took our story and wrote it all down
Little Angela and her friend POM Jenna and Edge Pumpkin and Pam Go together like eggs and spam Their book's real cute Rudy to toot Jenny and Anne and Jen Which was Pam
I mean it's just so sweet It's the best We got an original song Written about our friendship And our book by Creed Creed He just recorded that at home With his guitar
I mean it's so special to me Well I just loved that trip down memory lane, and you know what? I think we should take a break, and when we come back, we can all share our favorite creed moments. Pura is the smart way to fragrance your home. Customize your scents with app control. Schedule them to fit your life and enjoy premium fragrances that last. And here's something to celebrate. When you start today, your first fragrance set is free. It's the perfect time to discover why everyone's switching to Pura. But hurry, this offer is for a limited
time only. Go now to Pura.com and claim your free set before it's gone. Hi, I'm Nancy Cartwright. You may know me better as the voice of Bart Simpson. On Simpsons Declassified, we're diving into the mysteries that keep the Simpsons forever young. Have you ever wondered how the Simpsons regularly predicts future events? Who better to ask than the show's creators, performers, and writers, the celebrity guests. Be sure to follow and listen to Simpsons Declassified wherever you get your podcasts. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right
match with BetterHelp. Better Help therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies.
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and I think it's time for our Office Ladies team to share their favorite creed moments. We always like to kick this off with a fan letter. This one is from Luke B in Iowa, who said, Creed is my absolute favorite character. And then in parentheses, said, no offense. None taken Luke.
Because of his incredible one-line, insane fly-by comments that many times go overlooked. Season 2, Episode 14, is one of those when he comes in while everyone is trying to figure out what happened in Michael's office. Spoiler alert, it was poop. Creed makes the comment, quote, someone making soup? I believe it's one of the most underrated lines in the entire show. It's such a great random throwaway.
It really is. It really, really is. All right, well, who wants to go first? I'll go first. Okay, Sam. All right, mine was a toss-up between the old man's smell comment and this one. Hey, do you want to tell Stanley that I have asthma?
Because I don't. If it gets out, they won't let me scuba. If I can't scuba, then what's this all been about? What am I working toward? It's so pure. I love it so much. Cassie, what's yours? So my all-time favorite is from murder when Michael,
everyone's doing like the New Orleans characters, and Michael tells Creed that there's been a murder, and Creed's like, oh, yeah, I'll be right back. And then you see him running away. But it's more of a sight gag. So this is my runner-up. Yo, is this his new chair? No, he hasn't picked one yet.
When Pam gets Michael's old chair, I get Pam's old chair. Then I'll have two chairs, only one to go. I'm like, what the heck? I love that one. Angela, what's yours? Okay, mine is from the episode Ultimatum in season seven. So we talk about this a little bit with Creed, but if you remember, Pam has a conference room meeting, and she is putting up a New Year's resolution board
in the office so everyone can try to work towards their new resolution. And she asked different people, what is their resolution? And here's what Creed said. I love it, and then I have a part two. Creed, I noticed you don't have a resolution on the board. What's yours? I want to do a cartwheel, but real casual,
I can not make a big deal out of it, but I know everybody saw it. There's one stunning, gorgeous cartwheel. How's it going? I'm having little trouble motivating. Then, later in that episode, Aaron does a cartwheel in the bullpen. And Creed's reaction is amazing. One, two, three.
I did it. I did a cartwheel. Fuck you. Fuck you. God. Okay. That's it. He just cusses her out.
He's so pissed. All right, Jenna. What about you? All right. Well, I have two. I couldn't. side. My first one is from gay witch hunt. I love this talking head. I'm not offended by homosexuality. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors, in the mud and the
rain. And it's possible a man slipped in. It would be no way of knowing. I just love it. I think he delivers it so well. And then my other favorite is from Fun Run. I've been involved in a number of cults, both as a leader and a follower. He had more fun as a follower. But you make more money as a leader. I mean, it's true. I mean, come on. I mean, come on.
It's so good. Well, I think we should dig into some fan favorite creed moments. BuzzFeed wrote an article titled 27 Creed Bretton moments that will never not be funny. That's how many there are. There's 27, but this doesn't even include deleted scenes and all the other ones that are probably going to be discovered now in the superfan episodes. So in addition to all the ones we just shared, here are some that make all of the fan favorite lists. Okay. I'm going to just share five because there are so many.
Okay. All right. In Coypon, when Michael says, I could get a fish for a five-cent worm, and Crete says, you're paying way too much for worms, man. Who's your worm guy? I love who's your worm guy. Everybody loves that one. Number two, in Niagara Part 2, we learned this about Creed. Dwight says, Parley, my office, five minutes. Pam says parlay. Creed says pirate code. He wants to meet.
Pam goes, So everyone here knows pirate code? And Creed says, I understand it. I can't speak it. Number three, I completely forgot about. And are you ready? What is it? In the episode negotiation,
Creed makes this very fair but disgusting observation. He says, You can only ever ooze two things. sexuality and puss. I do not remember that. That's so gross. Number four, in Dundra Mifflin Infinity, when he actually uses the printer ink to dye his hair
so he could look younger. Remember Michael's like, I would have printed more things, and he's like, but there's no ink, and then it cuts to Creed. Lastly, number five, this makes many, many people's lists. In fact, it's also one of Creed Bratton
in real life's favorite moments. He talked about it with us. Everyone loves it when Creed got to be the manager in search committee. Mm-hmm. There's a compilation clip of this day. It's pretty long, but I'm going to play you the first 50 seconds. We need a new manager. Keep it running.
Do I love being the manager? I love my kids. I love real estate. I love ceramics. I love my job. I love wrestling. Find out what language this is. Most frankly, there, the cloth near my star, e-mer.
or bot. Got it. Okay. Team building. On this side of the room, Stanley, Phyllis, Jim, Ted Elroy. On this side of the room, Pam, Meredith, Phyllis, Creed. He never called a meeting. Bo body.
Bo body. What is the first B stand for? What are we doing? We're making acronyms. Okay. What is the first B stand for? Um... Business.
I like it. Business. Good. Kevin. All right, the O. That's just part of his time as a manager, but it's the best. When he pulls up and he tosses his keys to no one, and then his bow body, and you know what, you can see John laughing. Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah, he's cracking up.
Well, Creed was John's weakest spot, right? Like, whatever. His Achilles heel, what do you call that? Yes, it was for sure. Yeah, he never regained composure. when Creed was like, you're not real, man. Exactly. Well, I love the character of Creed so much. I love how he came about, Lady, that's just so organically. Like, the writers did not sit down in the room and think him up.
It's like they found him. He was a little treasure just sitting on our set doing background work. Oh, yeah. I would dare to say the writers had no idea the treasure chest that was going to be Creed. Well, now we like to do our areas of interest. Angela, do you want to kick us off? Yes, I am very excited about mine. And so are people that wrote in. Eva S from Tennessee wrote in and said, one of my favorite things about Creed is creed thoughts.gov. Can you read some of the entries? They are so funny. Thanks, love you guys. And Elise Kay from Minnesota said I remember reading hilarious
blog posts from Creed on NBC's website back in the day. Can you try to find these and discuss them? Well, this was my area of interest. I was so excited. This website is still active, you guys. What? Yes. I found it. Creedthoughts.gov. It's there. That's ridiculous. Yes. You just go to creedthoughts.gov. It's there. Really? That's nuts. That's crazy. So the blogs were written by our writers and writers assistants. They were really popular. And when you go to the site, it has a list of blogs. There are entries from May 2007 to August 2008. So there's a lot of blog entries, and they're pretty long. They're full of classic
creedisms, but I grabbed one to share. All right. It is from June 26, 2008. I've always liked uniforms. When I was a kid, I wore sailor suits every day until I was eight. People called me, I'm sorry. Oh, my goodness. Where is this going? I'm sorry. People called me Captain Crapt Stick because of how I dress and the fact that I would carry around a stick with me that I used for poking all sorts of crap. I still have my sailor suit hanging proudly in my closet, but I only break it out when a special lady comes over. It doesn't fit so well anymore, but I still look darn cute in it. In my opinion, every job should have a uniform. Fast food workers, gas station attendance, exterminators, these guys all have it covered already.
I'm pushing for the jobs that make you waste time every morning deciding what to wear. Take my job, for instance. I know I'm not allowed to wear shorts because every time I do, I get yelled at. I also can't wear vests without shirts underneath, so I'm locked into wearing a certain combination of clothing every day. But there are just too many choices. If it were up to me, I'd implement an office worker uniform so you could just wake up every morning, go to your uniform closet, and three seconds later, you're all set. My uniform would consist of three items and three items only. This is fascinating. This has gone in so many directions. I know. I've learned so much. I know, right? Number one, navy blue sweatpants. These are the first item because
they're the most important. When I go home, the first thing I do is put on navy blue sweatpants. You can't find a more comfortable piece of clothing. I thought this is so relatable. The color is great because you can spill all you want and nobody's the wiser. All in all, if the uniform doesn't include navy blue sweatpants, I don't want the job. Number two, a vest. No shirt required. Vests are amazing inventions. They cover up your nipples, which society has decided are unacceptable to see for some reason.
And they're classy. You want to class up a joint? Throw on a vest. You want to add some more class? Make sure that vest is leather. Number three. Wait, I just, so far, we're wearing a leather vest, no shirt, and navy blue sweatpants. Yes.
Okay. Although if you want a different type of material vest, that's fine. But leather is the classiest. Right. Number three. Final item, right? Because he only wants three items. Is it shoes?
Comfy slippers. Oh. Right after I change into my navy blue sweatpants, I slide on my shirt. sheepskin-line slippers. Talk about comfort. These little puppies make it feel like you're walking on a field of soft, paralyzed sheep. I say paralyzed only so you don't picture the sheep as moving. If I could wear slippers to work every day, I'd probably start caring about my job. These three items could change the workplace as we know it. I'm serious, America. Just think about how much more productive we would all be as a country if all office workers wore navy blue sweatpants, vests without shirts,
and comfy slippers. We'd be a comfortably dressed productivity superpower. And honestly, isn't that what all this fighting is about anyway? Lady, I think someone could wear this as a Halloween costume and have like the ultimate deep cut office costume. Oh, that is brilliant, Jenna. Yeah. If someone wore a vest with navy sweatpants, no shirt. And the like sheep lined, right? Is that what he said? Sheepskinned slippers. Yeah. That's your Creed costume right there. It sure is. And if you want to be classy, it's a leather vest. And you're going to be quite comfortable. I don't know, well, what part of the country you live in, you might be a little chilly, but... Please, if anyone dresses in this Creed outfit for Halloween, will you tag us? I hope we can find it, because that's brilliant.
Yeah, I would like to have that. Okay, there it was. That was my Creed area of interest. These blogs are hilarious. I could have read them all day. Great job writers and writers' assistants of the office. I bet they were a lot of fun to write. Well, lady, my area of interest was inspired by a fan letter. It is from Elsa S. Who said, The character of creed seems to draw a lot of inspiration from the real-life creed.
With the lines sometimes blurred between the two, can you share what aspects of creed the character are fictional and which are real? Well, lady, it's true. Over the years, we have shared a lot about how Creed's real life often found its way into the character of Creed, but also how sometimes we don't know what's real and what's fiction. For sure. So I thought it might be fun to do a little Creed Bratton Factor Fiction as my area of interest. Well, lady, I thought we should get to the bottom of this. And why not just go to the source? With Creed? Yes. That's so great. I made a list of questions for the real creed to find out which aspects of his character come from fact, which ones are purely fiction.
Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we'll get him in here and we'll ask him my questions and also fan questions from our mailbag. Love it. The Twisted Tale of Amanda Knox is an eight-episode Hulu original limited series that blends gripping pacing with emotional complexity. offering a dramatized look as it revisits the wrongful conviction of Amanda Knox for the tragic murder of Meredith Kircher and the relentless media storm that followed. The Twisted Tale of Amanda Knox is now streaming only on Disney Plus. During the Volvo Fall Experience event,
discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every Christmas. morning commute. This September, Lisa, 2026 X-E-90 plug-in hybrid from $599
biweekly at 3.99% during the Volvo Fall Experience event. Conditions supply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to
explore Volvo. com. Jen, I was in a hotel a while back. I think it was in New Orleans. And, you know, when the office channel
comes along, you come back in your room and there's nothing but office stuff, you know? Yeah. So this one episode comes on, and you're asking me about the cartwheel. Oh, yes. I love the cartwheel moment.
And there's a look on your face when I'm talking. It's the sweetest, I've got to tell you, it's the sweetest look. It's so endearing. You're going, and just like my kid or something, and just so pleased with dad. And I didn't really notice how sweet it was born. That's a great little moment there, you know. This little tiny stuff. It is.
We all had to pick sort of for the episode today, our favorite creed. moment. And that is mine. That's Angeles. It's so sweet. It's just because it's so sweet. It really is. I mean, I'm just kind of, oh, I just want to do this thing. And I'm, you know, and, oh, gosh. And Pam's really rooting for you. And she's rooting for me too. You know, it's just great. Well, listen, guys, here we are. We've jumped in. Creed is in studio with us. We're already chit-chatting. Yep. You guys carpooled together. You told me it was eventful. Well, here's the thing. We are neighbors. We shared this before. So Creed's like, just text me
And I'll meet you out And so I pull up and he gets in And we start the drive And I went a different way than I normally go And then I couldn't figure out how to get on the freeway You're arguing with Siri I was arguing with Siri And then Creed goes, I got this
He was like, all you need is Creed I was like, all you need is Creed That's true We put that on a T-shirt Put that on a coffee mug for sure But then she gets on the freeway And there's someone going to say she Come on, what are you doing?
And she's just, she drives around to the right and drives around to flip some, no, she did not, she did not. She did not. Here's the thing. It was the ramp when you get on, and it says one car per green. And there's two cars. You were irate. I was. You were a little bit.
The light turns green. Neither of them go. How dare they? And then I guess I got a little sassy. You did. And Creed goes, creed said, I think that's Texas attitude in California driving. There's another mind. And I said, but this gets stuff done.
Because she just shut around him and just, boom, you were gone. Ben Creed started laughing so hard, and we just got so tickled. It was so good. It made me laugh. He was like, we have to tell everyone how sassy you are on the freeway. I'm just saying, just abide by the law. Do the things we all are supposed to do. Turn signals.
Turn signals. And then I'm not going to call you a dumb, dumb. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. Yeah. She's not arguing with this. No, not at all.
Creed, I want to kick things off. I have some questions for you. And these are things about your character, Creed Bratton, that we would like to know if they are also true about you, the real Creed Bratton. Because you know your character blurred the lines of fact and fiction sometimes. It's confusing being me. It is? I speak to myself in the third person a lot because sometimes I don't even know where I'm coming from.
And I question, I question my own motives. This should be an interesting session then. Yes, it should be. We'll see what happened. I'm actually to see what he's going to say. Okay, well, here's the first question. Were you in a band called the grassroots? Yes, I was.
We know this is true. This is true. I think they know this, the fans, yes. So that is fact. Fact. It's just what we're saying, fact, fact. So how long were you in the band? Fact.
No, I was in the band. I did four albums, so it was four years. A very, wow. Yeah. Four albums in four years. That's very prolific. We put an album out of a year. Wow.
Y'all were busy. We were busy. Okay. Here's the next question. Did you ever have a radio show called Wacky Weed Creed? Not fact. Okay. Total fiction.
That's Oscar. Oscar thought that, but he was wrong. Okay. Were you in an iron lung as a teenager? Briefly. Wait, what? No. Come on.
No, okay, I wasn't. But do you see how you had us? This was what it was like being on set with you because we'd be like, really? And then you'd start laughing. When I was a kid, I would do this all the time for just a defense mechanism to tell stories all my life. And sometimes I would get people and they would believe. I have this innate ability to make people believe what I say, as you know. Yes.
And some people would find out that I was kidding. And they would get angry sometimes, you know. I finally had the period of time where I had to stop just josh and around. Josh and around, because people who took it took it too. I was, you know, just being an a... Yeah. All right. Next one.
Have you ever grown or eaten mung beans in real life? I have. I've done both. Really? Yes, I've eaten them. I've praised them. I've had little shrines for mung beans in my home. It's kind of like a worship thing, actually.
Yeah. Is this... Is there any part of this that's true? No, but mung beans are, you know, I like... I think I like alfalfa and ratty sprouts more than mung beans. But I do, there's a slight, small subcoccal of my heart that likes mung beans. You're a very healthy eater. I am, and I watch what I eat, you know.
Yeah. Did you really eat mung beans on the office? Did they give you actual mung beans? Did you ever eat them? Right. But I did eat them. And what did they taste like? And I ate that potato, by the way, too.
You did the raw potato? I talked about that. Yeah. When they switch out the apple for the potato. I absolutely ate the raw potato. And I couldn't tell that much difference, you know, that I don't have a really great sense of spell. Wait, that's so funny.
I chomped right down on that animal. And now, wait, what does a mung bean taste like? I've never had one. Memorable, some. Memorable. There used to be a song back in the 50s. Memorable mung beans, I recall. Now it's memorable mung beans.
I can't remember the exact melody of it now. But it's kind of like spring that's gone a little rancid. That's, it sounds like a bean that has turned, mung bean. It sounds like maybe something that's fermenting. That's exactly what it is, Jen. It's a fermented bean. Okay. But it's a fresh, and the irony, too, it's a brand new fresh, brand new germinating out, starting
its life, but it's already rancid at the start of its life. kind of like some people's careers but anyway here we go all right next question do you have a daughter I have a daughter ami
do you have how many kids do you have I have two children you have a son and a daughter okay Bo and Ami and now you're a grandpa and now I'm a grandpa
so great have you ever been in a cult that you know of what are the statute of limitations that stuff like this. Oh, no. I, I, I, I, I, I, there was a time.
It was a time that people put me up to it in a, like a white robe. I recall and, uh, burn some incense. Well, right now, as you know, there is a cult of creed because of the show. There's no joke. So I guess you are the leader of a cult now. Well, right now, I, maybe I was when I was younger, but right now I am a leader of a cult because there's the cult of creed. And my lawyer recently, there's, there's,
there's people all over the world now. Anytime you can see the office, they've started the little cult. There's a little thing there. Would they burn incense, you know, treat, treat the chant my name. I was in Norway, this is no joke.
My lawyer said there was a heavy metal group there that's part of the cult of creed. They've sacrificed a small animal in your name. What? And I had to call them and said, look, I appreciate the gesture, but cease and desist. Can't do this.
Can't do it. Horrible. I don't hurt anything in my name. Don't hurt anything like, because I know. It's horrible. Because that's not you. No. I would not want that.
No, I would not want that, you know. No. I mean, the thought of it that they did that for me was moving, but not not what they did. Yeah. Their passion for your character. The passion for my character, yes. Is any of that true? No.
No. Oh, my God. Read again, dang it. What are you doing? At a boom. At a boom. At the very end, you had that twinkle in your eyes. And I was like, son of a bitch.
I remember the thing I said about. We still believed it. We believe it every time. You were just in Norway. So I thought, oh, I don't know. I was. Maybe. Oh, that's such a beautiful country, too.
Yeah, I've heard. It's really pretty. Yeah. Lovely, lovely. Clean. So clean. With no creepy cults. And there's no creepy cults.
No one has sacrificed any animals, folks in my name. Not that I know of. All right. Next question. Are you good at chess? I'm, I can play. I'm not going to beat I'm not going to beat rain
or my son but I can play a small child who's just learned they've just shown him the basic basic moves you know
he's still working to where the word move the night stuff like that could probably beat him okay can use scuba I used to
until I broke my ear drum oh how did you break your eardrum this is true now this is true I was horseing around in a pool with a bunch of friends in college for the water polo team and for somebody throwing through a football. So we were starting to play football in a pool. Yeah. Not a good
idea. And we didn't have our little, those days you don't have the protected things for years they have for water polo players. Now, yeah. So I just caught an elbow, broke the, broke the ear drum. And then, uh, then I was still able to scuba dive. And I got it. I had a scuba. I had the whole thing. Did scuba dive. Yes. Then I was in Hawaii with my six. And then I was in Hawaii with my son, and I was in the way we were going down, and we were just snorkeling. And the woman next to me dropped her mask in her snorkel, being a gentleman. I went down after to get it for her. I went down too far. Pow. It broke the tympatic membrane again. And now it's just messed up. What is that like for you when you fly in an airplane with the air pressure?
It's not bad. It's not bad. I get anything else. She still have to clear a little more, but not bad. But I came up and I could see, and I couldn't find my way back to the surface and I was panicking a little bit because my body wouldn't go in the direction that I was trying to swim. Yeah. I got up there and Beau was laughing.
He said, did you get it? He looks at me. He said, Dad, you're white. And I went, oh, he jumped in. And I was panicking. Yeah, that's scary. Yeah. You lost your sense of balance and, and, yeah, direction.
I lost all my equilibrium. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. But I'm okay now, folks. Yeah. All right. Do you have four toes on one of your feet? I was, yes, I do. On my right foot, I was, uh...
No. No, no, I know this one. You have ten toes. Yeah. How do you know? You've seen my feet. I don't know. I've seen your feet. I've seen your feet. When? Okay, you were barefoot, I think in the finale, when we find out you're homeless and you've been living in the office. Yeah, you're right. You're right. I'm pretty sure. You're brushing your teeth and You're in your towel or something, and you walk out. Okay, but a better story is that I was in in Scandinavia again at a clog dancing.
Stop it. And some drunk Viking stomped on my toe and broke it. And then there's a hole with hairy feet that covers the hole. That's what I said to Steve in the scene. It's an ad lib. Do you remember that? No. There's a little ad lib under my voice going like to, well, the hair, I said the hair covers it up mostly.
Oh, no, yes. The hair covers it up. The hair covers it up. But not the part about the clogging in. No, no, no. No, no, I should have. That was came later. Okay.
All right. My final factor fiction question, can you catch a fish with your bare hands? Well, that would be really, they're so slippery. Yeah. Now, I really doubt it unless you're Bruce. Bruce Lee probably could. Yeah. If he goes around.
Someone like that. Yeah, someone's super quick. Somebody, he'd have to go, he'd have to go like this, whack, and get a finger up in the mouth. Yeah. Hop, like that. I'm impressed that you came up with how to do it so quickly. I think... That's exactly what you'd have to do.
That's so smart. If you tried to grab by the tail, listen to have a big spiky tail, you could grab it like this and go, the tail would stop like that. You know why I think you know this? Right. I'll never forget. During the pandemic, we would trade texts about what are you watching,
what are you binge watching? And Creed was like, alone. You got to see it, Anne. You've got to watch alone. I love that stuff. So then Josh and I get into it. it. And we start watching it. And I'm texting Creed. And I was like, Josh wants you to know he'll never look at a small animal the same way again because they're all so hungry. It's like a squirrel.
Anything they can get. Oh, yeah. It's a, it's a meat. It's a barbecue thing, you know. So they're out there just catching fish by hand and trying to trap little animals. They're making their own nets and stuff. And they're trying to trap animals because they're so hungry. Twice in my life. When Beau was little, we were fishing. Bass fishing. This is before I got in a trout fishing. And I look at him like, just, hey, bow. And I reach it, and I go, walking out a turtle. The water is like this.
Second time, I'm with a guy. This is before, way for the office, and after the grassroots, I'm working, we're just doing labor work. Sice, cutting down fields for fire, fire breaks. Sure. Like that. And I look down these two holes like this, and I go, hey, Ray, he's down the road like this. And I go, I have gloves on like this. And I look, and I drop the side, like this quietly,
and go up through the holes. And I go, and this is honest and God truth. I go, and I grab two squirrels, swirl in each hand like this and hold them up like to all the other guys working there and went, going, how in the hell did you do that? It was a hero moment. So you probably could grab a fish back in the day, I would say. I had some of a turtle and two squirrels with your bare hands. I did, girls.
Okay. I did. I'm kind of proud of that, actually. You can see, kind of chuffed. as the English would say. I didn't know that squirrels lived in holes in the ground. They do. There are squirrels that they burrow.
Ground squirrels. And they're smaller. And we actually are having a thing in our backyard. They're like, they're burrowing in all these little places in our yard. Social media is not much on the ground scores. They're more the popular ones with the Vidal Sassoon coats and stuff. They get all the press. They get all the good press.
You guys, I have a weird question. Sure. And this is something that I muse about with my family. My kids are annoyed by this question. but I am haunted by it. Oh. And it has to do with squirrels and birds. Where are all of the dead squirrels and the dead birds?
Where are they? Why don't we see them? The crows. Where do they go? The ravens. Oh, other animals come to eat them. Other animals come and pick them up. Like, why don't, where are they?
Are they dead in the tree? Are they dead in the ground? They're in their bellies. Like, where are they? Well, the ravens, if you see stuff on the side of the road, you see the ravens down there, take cleaning them up. I guess that's true. I mean, I, this is really gross, but there's a hawk that kind of lives in my neighbor's tree. And I walked out one day, like, to go to my little garage office.
And there were like innards just in the like the pavers, like little tiny intestine, little tiny. And I was like, oh my gosh. And Josh was like, I bet the hawk got a squirrel or something. But I'm saying like birds and squirrels who have died by natural causes. Or suicide. Oh, God. Right. You don't know.
We don't know. We don't know. So not something that was prey, but like something, like a very old bird or something or a disease, like a squirrel that died of a disease. And no one wants to eat it and it's just dead somewhere. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, I think Creed, you kind of answered the question, which is that when an animal dies, another animal will eat that dead animal, I guess.
If the animal's there, let's say it's old, it's writing its memoirs, that little nagging cough, then boom, it's done. It's over like that. The hawks and the ravens watching him, you know, checking their watch it to see what they're going to die. I don't she like souping today. I'm just going to wait it out. Raven's got his little Fitbit on. You're like, well, I just wondered if in all of your nature show watching, if they explain where squirrels and birds go to die.
I can tell you this interesting story. I'm at my backyard on Ethel, when I lived on Ethel and Longridge, doing the only one the show was on. And I was out of the pool one day, and I was sitting out there having my green tea and after work, and I look up at the U's at the house. And there's a little bird nest in there with little baby birds. And all of a sudden, I say the squirrel comes down a pipe, comes over, grabs a baby bird. Because squirrels will eat baby birds.
Squirrels are terrible. Squirrels. You don't know this. Squirrels ate a hummingbird right outside my window. They're the evil creatures of the world. They are mean and they're terrible. There should be, they boycott a lot of things, but squirrels should be right on the list, you know. I know.
I'm wrong with you, Jen. You're vicious. Well, on that note, squirrels are evil. I would like to kick off our fan Q&A. All right, let's do it, lady. Fans wrote in, Creed, they love you so much. Oh. Let's start with Oliver T. from Wolverhampton, England, who says, I love Creed.
He is my favorite character in the show and didn't get nearly enough screen time. My question is, what was his favorite Creed moment or storyline? Man, just there's so, you know, you know, there's just so many. And by the way, Wilberton, Walton, where's, Wilverhampton. Wolverhampton, yes, sir. I used to think, well, you know, I can't capable of doing more stuff. I should get more. In retrospect, the lines they gave me just the right amount was perfect.
It was perfect. Too much, a little more. It would have lost the appeal, I think, you know. I think it was just, and I thought about this a lot. it turned out just right. Absolutely perfect. Boy, well, I have to say, obviously, I enjoyed it. It was scary, a scary, you know, baptism by fire
but the scene with the Halloween episode with Steve working with that at his rate of speed that he works at, you know, and not knowing what was going to happen. That was very satisfying. But all the little bits, you know, which ones, Pam, you know, Did Michael get his new chair yet, you know? The thing with you with the Nicholson's, you know, what do you do? Yeah, well, they have this bag of Nicholson. You're a useless.
Yeah, and you're like, don't worry about Andrea. She's the office bitch, yes, stuff like that. And everything that thinks it would be the manager when I was driving the Porsche and playing the finale. But it's all those little bits just to keep going, the fodder that kept going. I got such joy out of it. And I laughed, looks like you did. Every time we'd have a table read, I get to see, oh, boy, I can't, I just can't wait to do this line, you know? Yeah.
Well, we did get a fan question from Layton R. in Folsom, California, who said, Your time as acting manager in season seven is a fan favorite moment. And Layton wants to hear, did you enjoy that spotlight, or did you prefer being the mysterious side character? Oh, I just said it, didn't I? You did. You said you liked it. I did like it. I certainly enjoyed driving the Porsche. Yeah. Really? Have you ever driven a car like that before? Yeah, I had one. I had a Porsche back in my grassroots days. Yeah. You've always loved a zippy car. I do like it. But I still have a zippy car. I've ridden with you and your zippy car. I'm not going to talk about how you drive.
No, no, you're right. You're right. But Matt, a lot of people don't know this, you normally have sandbags and a barricade. And he'd be behind a barricade just in case there'd be a stop for the tires. And in any shoot normally, Matt was just standing there with the camera. And I come up there right in front of him like that. He trusted me. And I said, are you sure? I trust you. Are you sure?
I trust you. And we did it. Dang. That's amazing. I didn't know that. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Most people would never do that normally.
You know, Creed, there are a lot of your moments that ended up getting deleted for time, which is true of all of us. But there are Reddit threads upon Reddit threads dedicated to Creed deleted scenes. You are like the favorite character for deleted scenes and deleted moments. Really? Oh, my gosh. Yes. So many fun ones.
Wow. Yeah. And I think a lot of those are being added back to the Peacock Superfan episodes. And that's going to be so fun. Yeah. That's amazing, you know. Yeah. Greg, we couldn't use the
Bruce Cruz when I played the guitar. Yes, yes, that was one of them. It was just too long. Yeah, yeah. He said, he's so good. He said, he's so good, but it was just too long. I said, I hope you understand, but we love it, but it's just too long, you know. Yeah.
A little tidbit there. I recorded it the night before at the studio with Dylan O'Brien and Bob Field, but it's grandtones. Sure. And then I just came in the studio, and he had his, left-handed strap. So I just, by the way he plays, it's different than a lot of left-handers. So I just turned it over like this and played for it.
So when you see me playing that left-hand guitar, a lot of people say, well, he's a right-hander. He wouldn't be playing that guitar. So that's the explanation. That's a little nugget there. And also, we were going to play it live, but we realized out there, the reber was going to be bouncing on the amps and stuff. It was to logistically impossible. We had to mime it.
We had to mime it, you know. And I really wanted to play live. Yeah. Yeah, but it's okay. But you got to eventually play live on the set, which is so beautiful. Yes, yes, yes. And that's one of the most touching moments when the fans are there at my show and I close with all the faces, you know.
And I get, I get, I'm looking out of the, you know, it's amazing. Emotional connection from, it's not the song. The song is good, but without the office, we're saying goodbye to all of us. We're seeing goodbye to us. And that song, gets that emotion out of people. It's powerful. It's a beautiful moment. All right.
Fan question from one of our very own office ladies members, Ainsley. She wants to know, what did you do on your computer while other cast members were filming scenes? Spider Solitaire. Oh, yeah? Yeah, Spider Solitaire. Because I didn't have a working computer. I think only Oscar had one for a long time in the beginning. But I think eventually everybody got one.
Everybody got one eventually. I didn't. Ever? No, I don't think so. Maybe I did. So you never had Internet? You just had the Solitaire game? I'm demented someone because I've had, you know, facialty and stuff, you know.
I can't believe that. I might have. Is it possible that you got Internet and didn't know? And no one told you? That's probably the case. And you're so. Sometimes I was like, oh my gosh, great. The way you were positioned in the bullpen, no one has.
You could see your computer. Who knows what he did, and you only played Solidair. Oh, that's very fun. I sure wrote a lot of music on that show. You did. In the green room. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah?
I was always grabbing that guitar and going to the green room waiting for, you know, everybody to show up. And I wrote a bunch of us. I wrote two albums in that green room, basically, and in my trailer. I didn't know that. All right, let's see. We have a fan question from Sabrina S. and her fiancé, Joey, from Chicago, Illinois.
And they said, our question for Creed, who has clearly had and continues to have such an iconic life, what do you consider to be one of your biggest accomplishments? Gosh, well, it has to be the road I was going down in my life. Wow, I'm going to get modeling or anything with my family. and all my debaucheries and stuff, you know, back in my rock and roll days, that now I have such a tight, loving family with such support in the family. It turns out to be all this other stuff is wonderful,
but that family connection is so strong. That gives me most joy and my friendships and my friends, you know. And I'm now putting my hands out at my two girls who are like my daughters from the show, basically, you know. And you always were kind of in a way, you know. I always felt that. Well, we talked about this earlier, Creed, that our text thread with you, the three of us, brings us such joy. We can always count on you for a cat video. Oh, yes.
Or just how you refer to us, you always call Jenna, Jen. You call me Pumpkin and you call yourself Grandad Creed. Granddad Creed. That's true. Yeah. Lucky us. Lucky us. Yeah.
Well, Creed, okay. More questions. more questions for you, but you're just such a delight. I'm just, from the minute, like, when I pulled up, he said, I just have a spring in my step today. Yep, good to see you guys. Getting to see us. So sweet. Okay.
Creed, did you keep anything from the set after the series ended? You know, a sprinter van, a couple of cameras, some sound, some sound, noggara sound recorders, you know, like that. But, you know, I can, by the way, if you can get a hold of me, I can sell them to you. a little discreet scale. No, I saved the little samurai warrior with the fat samurai warrior with the fan on my desk. I have that on my mantle. That's great. But I asked permission, not like the character.
I actually went to production and said, can I? Yes, of course. Of course that. And the suit that I wore in the finale when I'm in the white suit. That kind of a gray, that kind of linen suit. with a little purple thing and they're very it was tailored for me and stuff too they just gave that to me so i got to keep that so that let me think about that so the um yeah the the samurai guy and the uh and a couple of and maybe a picture there might be a picture from the wall there yeah you had a
bunch of plaques on the wall by you they made they came up with pictures of me and my kids and stuff and put them but we all had that right all yeah yeah that was so great about the show they put personal stuff up on the desk, you know. You also had that dust buster on the wall next to you. Yes, I never used it. I never used it because somebody else would always come by. When I do my show and I sing the office theme, I talk about you and Phyllis and I always say, you know, Phyllis and Angela were the planning committee, you know.
A lot of people don't know this that Phyllis and Angela are method actors. So art design and props and people would come in and want to set the office up for the... No, they'd chase them all out. Then you guys would do all the work. We'd be home at night after showers and dinner. You'd still be there sitting up the office the next day. And, of course, they go, oh, it's probably true then. There's no telling what people believe about us.
They're not. They're not. Just like, they're getting it, you know. Of course they would. They're actors, you know. Someone asked me one time, they were like, Creed said you're 411, but I think. you're a little taller. Are you telling people I'm 411? I took days 311, 411. I know it's changes
around on stage. All right, guys, whatever Creed says on stage, don't believe. It's true. Or believe, but with like a grain of salt. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It's there for your amusement, folks. All right, Creed. Up next, we're going to do our call sheet questions. Okay, number one, what was your first job in entertainment? 1964, and I became an extra on camera on a movie called Cast a Giant Shadow with Mel Shabelson and the director. I fell in love with his daughter, Lynn, and we had an affair in the Greek islands after that.
But in the movie, the movie was Frank Sinatra, John Wayne, Yule Brenner, Senta Burger, and it was the Colonel Mickey Marcus, Kirk Douglas, who's played Colonel Mickey Marguards, the Israeli war for independence. What did you have to do in your scene? I was in English. I was there in a background. Yeah. But I got paid.
I was in a uniform. And you were a British soldier. A British soldier standing there. But attention, like the camera came by. Oh, wow. My first movie. That's a lot of big names. It's a huge movie.
If you watch the movie, can you find yourselves in the scene? Yes. Yes, yes. But the side of my face. Okay. There's an interesting story from that. I'm standing on the set and leaning against this. this wall, Frank Sinatra is there, and he sees me over there.
And I said, I'm like, wow, it's Frank Sinatra. He comes over to me like this, you know, and he goes, hey, kid, you know. He said, that wall is going to explode here in a little bit with squibs in there like that. You might want to just, you want, oh. And I said, well, thank you, Mr. Stein. He said, it's all right. So he just pushed me, pulled me away from the things I wouldn't get blown up, you know. Thank you, Frank.
Wow. That's such a cool story that you had a conversation. Frank Sinatra. That's life. That's my life, perhaps. Wow. All right. Here is a question. Can you tell us all of the musical instruments that you play? It won't take long. Okay. Guitar, a little bit of piano, and a very little bit of mandolin. Okay. And a trumpet. I played trumpet for over 10, 12 years as a kid. That was my first instrument. Was trumpet? Trumpet. I did not know that. Yeah. That list is long. longer than our list, Creve.
That's right. But guitar is it, yeah. You have so many when you go to your place, you have like a wall of guitars. Yeah, yeah. Pretty cool. All right. What's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved?
So many. Iceland. You're going there. But I drove around for two weeks. No navigation, no maps or anything. maps or anything, just drove, because it's an island, so you can't get really lost, you know. Fascinating, fascinating place. I love, and I've gone back numerous times with my son, the Sacramento River out of Reading, and taking it all.
You can, and you're also the Klamath River at the Oregon, California border. Because you guys go fishing. We go fishing every year, practically, yeah. And we go to their back, I love it. I just love being on the river, the serenity, the beauty, and the fish, the beautiful fish. All catch and release, barbellous hooks. That sounds so peaceful. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think the fish look forward to being caught with us. You want to just chat for a second? Yeah, let me talk and see what's going on. Yeah, love the commercial treat. Thank you. Boat back to your kids. All right, it's a good. All right.
Next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Well, it's pretty boring. And pretty boring now. I read my books and I play my guitar and write my songs and do my yoga, swim. So I'll be one of this. I'll be swimming, doing yoga, you know. I like to go to Hugo's and have my almond energy pancakes, you know, meet my friends there. And you know that place. Love, love Hugo's. We love Hugo's. Yeah. They came in one day and said, hey, you were in. I went to, well, there you go. She knows a good pancake, obviously. So what kind of books do you like? Do you like fiction, nonfiction, both?
Both, both. Do you have something you've read recently that you like? We love to get out book shoutouts. I can't. I'm not really good at the names anymore. I basically have for a while, though, I have just written a book, a Western. It's on Amazon right now with my friend Nathan Edmondson called Buffalo. You did?
I wrote a book. We took two years to write the book. I had an eye. It's fact, I was talking about Hugo's. I was sitting in Hugo's one day, and this rider came by, who was Nathan. And he said, hey, I just want to tell you a big fan. And I said, I like, because he was an intelligent guy right off the bat. I went, sit down.
We started talking. He had to deal with Paramount for a couple of scripts. And I told him this idea I had. And next thing we know, we were taking hands to write this thing together. And you did. And we did. And we're out now, folks, Buffalo. I love a Western.
I'll go check that out. So I, it's getting back to your point, Jen. I read all the, the Cormac McCarthy, the Laramick Merchries, the Louis Lamores. Yeah. I love all those Westerns. sci-fi, Neil Steffeson, William Gibson. I just finished Hyperion for the second time. That's an amazing sci-fi.
All right. Last question. Favorite midnight snack? I don't eat at night. I know this. I don't. At 6 o'clock, when the sun goes down, then there's no food after that, you know. Yeah.
You don't eat after 6. No. And then your first meal in the morning, what is that? Um, I will have been recently. I used to just have a cup of coffee and then write for a while, you know. But now I've been getting into these little gluten-free blueberry muffins. Hmm. A trout turned me onto them.
But there's a place I go to Giorla, it's just called that I go down and then get these gluten-free blueberry muffins with my coffee. Then I go home and then I write for about an hour, then I'll have breakfast, you know. Do you write in a journal? I write a longhand. Yeah. And then I put it, but I've started to kind of know that I'm wasting a lot of time writing a longhand. But I didn't think I could do it other ways. But now I'm starting to kind of slowly type.
But it's like, it's like chicken back. Chicken back. It gets it. That's probably just as fast as writing longhand. How long have you kept a journal? Oh, a long time. Yeah. I think it's really important because the song lyrics are on their notes.
And I have a, in my day planner, I have all things I'm supposed to do. And then at night, I'll look at my day planner and I'll write out a little notion of plan and put it up in the kitchen. Your cheat sheet. The cheat sheet. This is what you, yeah, that's a short, abbreviated version of what I'm going to do that day so that I can get to the satisfaction of checking off that and then going to the planner and checking it again.
Yeah. Accomplishment. Did it. Double check accomplishment. Well, before we let you go, we got this letter from Juliana R in New York, who said, Creed came to my college as our fall comedian, and it was so exciting getting to listen to his music and hear him speak. I was on the Activities Council Board, so I even got to take a picture with him. What a gem.
And it's true, Creed. Your live shows are so great. Have you had a recent live show, or do you have one coming up that you can share about? I did a show recently with Rain and his guest with Pete Holmes. I sang three songs, and I think he was one of them, one of my new songs. Yeah, I go out. I'll be going in October to Hawaii, New Zealand, Australia, Singapore, and Japan for the month of October. So I'll be doing my shows then, too. That's amazing. And on the drive-in, you pointed out a place and you're like, I play there once a month. The baked potato. I played there for a long time coming in and just doing like four songs with the very channel of Tim Hockenberry and his band. And now I have a band called The Work.
with Dylan O'Brien, Charlie Ferreger, Davy Ferreger, Sebastian Lorenz. They're called the work. We just did jam in the van, jam in the van, and we just played also, I must myself, a solo show, two solo shows with the band at the baked potato. And we'll let you know. I want to go to the baked potato. It's a fun little room, venerable jazz room. Of course, I'm creeds pop and fokey stuff, but they allow me to play. So great. Well, one last thing, because you said this in the car and we said we would talk about
it, which is Creed told me, you know, years ago, I would have these Yankee swap Christmas parties with the cast and they would come over. And I haven't had one in a long time. Jenna, you've started having some with your family, but that big get-together of the cast, you know, life happened, kids and just busyness. And he got in the car and he's like, I just want you to know, I've been holding on to a Yankee swap gift I bought for 15 years. For your next party. It's true. Because right off the veil, I loved it so much.
And I was like, what? And he goes, I'm ready. You got to have your Yankee swap party and tell him what it is. I'm at a, what do they call it, a pawn shop or something like that? And I look down there and what it is, it's a toilet fishing, a toilet fishing game. We sit on the toilet and you lay this thing of a piece of paper. It's a lake. It's a lake.
And you spread it out on the floor and then it's got little fish, little magnet fish, and it's got a little fishing rod. And you go like this and you're on the toilet. go, and you drag the bag, you catch the fish, so you're fishing on the toilet. And I said, I really, because everyone will want this for sure. He's been holding on to it for like a decade. I would sit in my garage. It won't get rid of it. All right. Can I make a suggestion? It doesn't have to be December to have a fun Yankee swap party. This is true. Like, let's pick a time. I got to get this out of my life. December. Yeah. Let's, this party needs to happen early. It's going to be
office reunion slash cast friends slash Yankee Swap in July. Yes. I don't know. Maybe so. Yeah. All right. All right. All right.
Oh, my gosh. Girls, it's always, it's just a joy seeing you both. I love you both. You know them. Thank you for having me. And thanks for all the fans for those kind words. And, uh, oh, Crete's a lucky guy. Thank you.
We love you, Cree. I love you guys. Well, lady, I just loved having Creed in studio with us. I did too. It was such a treat. And as we finish up today, we got a fan letter from Jamie T. in Arizona. I really liked this. Jamie said, I have a theory as to what happened to Creed after the final episode.
Oh. I think after being taken away by the police, he jumped bail, used his passport with his name, William Charles Schneider and fled the country. He could now be living in a country with no extradition treaty with the United States and is the leader of a cult to make money. Probably not far off. It's true. It's probably pretty great, Jamie. But lady, did the NBC website say what Creed is up to? I couldn't find it. Oh, no. I search, if someone else out there found it on the NBC website, let me know. I got tons of clips of Creed, but I couldn't find like a where is he now thing. Okay.
But I did find this great article on Collider with a quote from Creed Bratton in real life about what he thinks happened to the character Creed. Okay. So I thought I would share that. So this article kind of breaks down everyone's final moments on the show. And Collider's like, you know, everyone gets kind of a happy ending except for Creed who gets handcuffed and is presumably going to prison for the crimes he's committed. Yes.
So Collider says you would think the logical place for Creed, now is prison, but here is what Creed Bratton, the actor, thinks. In an interview with the Tampa Bay Times in 2019, Bratton speculated about the character's future saying, quote, he never stayed in jail long. He got out pretty fast. He went on to suggest that Creed would have gotten pity from a talented defense attorney, scammed his way to freedom, and continued doing probably the illegal things that Creed does best. And honestly, Bratton makes a good point. After all, Creed got away with it this long, so why wouldn't he be able to escape justice again? Well, this is not too far off from Jamie's theories.
Exactly. But Cassie, you said that when you were walking Creed out, he had an idea of where we might be able to see Creed again, which I thought was pretty fun. Yeah, will you share your conversation? Yeah, I was like, oh, I would love to know what Creed is up to and maybe we'll get to know through the paper. And he was saying that he pitched to Greg that maybe one episode, We just see him working in the background at a random office.
So, like, I guess we just have to really be looking in the background for a creed catch. That would make me so happy. If Creed was just somewhere in the deep background, maybe he's at Softies, the toilet paper company. Or, you know what I would love? I would love to see him, like, delivering someone's meal at that little place where they eat lunch in the building. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Maybe he catches the documentary crew and immediately runs away. he's like not again. All right. Well, everyone, thank you so much for sending in your questions for all about Creed. And thank you to Creed for coming in and spending this afternoon with us. Oh, and we want to give a shout out to a project for Creed. He shared with us he performed in the YouTube series called Jam in the Van. It's a series where musicians perform in a van. And he's really great in it. We'll add it to our stories. I love it. Such a fun day. I love. our job. I love the cast of the office, and I love our Office Ladies community. Thank you guys so much. See you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is
Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.